it was the headline that dominated
President Donald Trump's daily news
briefing our most striking observation
to date is the powerful effect that
solar light appears to have on killing
the virus both surfaces and in the air
promoting a theory that Sun heat and
humidity appear to shorten the life of
the corona virus that research is
unconfirmed and it may prove not to be
true but that didn't start President
Trump
broadcasting it to millions and going
one step further and then I see the
disinfectant where it knocks it out in a
minute
one minute and is there a way we can do
something like that by injection inside
almost of cleaning suggesting
disinfectant could be used inside the
body but it sounds it sounds interesting
to me that's prompted a warning from
health authorities and the makers of
popular cleaners Lysol and Dettol that
no one should ingest bleach disinfectant
or any other hygiene products the US
Centers for Disease Control says it saw
a spike in calls to poison hotlines last
month because of people's exposure to
such chemicals which can be harmful even
to our skin it's not the first time
president Trump's used his podium to
push what he calls potential cures for
the virus there are promising therapy is
produced by Gilead and that's remedy sir
voir reservoir hydroxychloroquine and
the z-pak i think is a combination
probably is looking very very good but
according to early trials in China the
drug room de Sevilla has failed to treat
covert 19:00 and it's too early to know
about hydroxychloroquine is not a
medical
public health expert and and he doesn't
pass on the advice of his true medical
and public health experts I think most
people are smart enough to know that
they shouldn't be taking medical or
public health advice from President
Trump they should be listening to expert
opinions as for trumps heat and some
theory the World Health Organization
pointed to examples where the virus has
spread around the equator and southern
hemisphere the the evidence is not
providing supporting that theory so I'm
sorry we cannot hope that the summer is
going to have the effect that many
people hope it will the president is
convinced he's giving hope to millions
I'm not a doctor I'm here to present
ideas but many health professionals say
those ideas could prove dangerous alexei
o'brien
al jazeera